alors après après ta soirée du nouvel an
sur C8 normalement tu sais tous les gens
vont prendre des bonnes résolutions euh
comme je sais que tu as pas ta langue
dans ta poche je vais te montrer des
photos de personnes pour que tu leur
donnes des idées de bonnes résolution à
prendre si tu veux tu joues et et on
peut je peux le faire aussi he si tu
veux moi ça me dérange pas il y a plein
de gens que j'aime pas delphine a
note qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te
dise je viens chez toi pour passer un
bon
moment c'est bon merci c'est bon al
c'est la patronne de France Télévision
voilà écoute voilà voilà j'ai rien à
dire bonne résolution ma tête je suis en
pleine forme ta bonne résolution c'est
peut-être tu vas regarder le non mais
c'est bien regarde il attendu 3 4 ans
pour faire un truc qui tient la route
j'adore l'émission de Ferro le samedi
soir j'adore ça génial 100% logique ou
j'adore moi aussi mais j'adore Ferro
annalgo tiens ah nidalgo elle peut pas
quitter
Paris juste quitter Paris non mais c'est
on est en train de voir là dans mon
spectacle j'en parle un peu sur scène là
parce que tu Sandrine Rousseau oh
tu m'as fait un leasing là ouais ben je
vais te dire ce que je dis sur scène je
vous le dis à vous si vous pensez que
vous avez une vie de merde consolez-vous
en vous disant que chaque matin il y a
un mec qui se réveille à côté de
Sandrine
[Applaudissements]
r non c'est un truc de chansonnier allez
on arrête ce jeu on arrête on arrête on
arrête ce jeu allez on arrête c'est pas
pour nous c'est les sais qu'ils sont
capables ils sont capables de prendre la
phrase que j'ai dit de dire c'est du
sexis c'est pas ça c'est pour les
éisions qui peuvent se permettre de de
monter derrière tu vois nous en direct
nous on est comme on on est sans filet
et voilà tomb vous avez vu comme ça fait
de la peine un nounours qui tombe sans
rigoler vu ou pas c'est violent viol
t'inquiète pas je suis là c'est
papa non mais c'est vrai c'est un truc
de fou Patrick non on va arrêter ce jeu
tuas raison j'ai pas envie pas envie que
tu avec des g tu vois ce bien c'est que
je dis à la télé tu as trois mecs déjà
qui sont en train de taper c'est une
horreur et par contre dans mon spectacle
sur scène je fais un spectacle qui
s'appelle hommage et dessert où je rends
hommage à à Coluche à ginbourg au tonton
flingueur brassin et puis au milieu je
parle d'actu comme ça moi j'ai DESS
devant Patrick qui en télé parce qu'on
en parlait tout à l'heure dans ma loge
blch le peintre qui était chez moi qui
m'a fait ça là blanch c'est le peintre
qui peignait vachement stylé en vrai en
vrai merci c'est toi qui a dit ça de
quoi non j'ai rienci tu es Ventrilo
toi c'est Jeff non on parlait tout à
l'heure de de télé on disait on disait
on narrivait pas à sortir trois noms de
mecs qu'on aimait bien ah si si si si si
moi il y a plein de mecs j'aime bien
RMAN j'aime biena on aime bien les mêmes
mecs j'aime bien j'ai a des émissions
que je suis je suis fidèle le fait
entrer l'accusé j'aime bien le nouveau
mec qui fait fait entrer il est
vachement bien ouais rizé moi j'aime
bienp j'aime bien ruer je petit Ferro
j'aime bien il f ex Il BSE bien ouais ou
il y a plein de gens qui travaillent
très très bien qui t'aime pas hein qui
t'aime pas il y a pas beaucoup que
j'aime pas on est
obligé vas-y on est obligé de dire tous
les deux un animateur qu'on aime pas
même moi j'en j' Ren les photos moi je
rien à moi je le dis ben quand je
me revois moi non arrête arrête arrête
quand je me revois il y a des fois je me
revoie je me dis mais ferme ta
gueule non non non des mecs que j'aime
pas c'est très difficile parce que si
j'aime pas j'ai envie de le dire à tous
les mecs qui sont en trainent de taper
sur leurs réseaux sociaux si tuaimes pas
tu regardes pas et puis voilà siaimes
pas tu regardes
pas ch Pat c'est vrai on dirait une ch
si t'aimes pas tu regardes
pas tu les vois écrire sans celui-là je
l'aime pas et celui il est comme ça mais
jeis pas le regarde pas quoi alors il y
a ma mère qui me dit alors plusieurs
infos je vous dis à 19h34 alors déjà
Baba le 8 janvier tu reprends mais
n'oublie pas que le 9 c'est mon
anive voilà et là elle me dit comment
elle s'appelle maman ma mère ou
Jean-Claude son prénom
non Esther bon anniversaire alors c'est
le 9
janvier tu veux revenir elle me met les
sardines s'il te plaît tu
vois on va te faire un petit coup de
Sardin t'inquiète pas ah non non les
sardines elle adore les sardines ben
ouais mais je te je te remercierai
jamais assez cette chanson mais c'est
grâce à Cyril parce que cette chanson
elle était elle était sortie 10 ans
avant et ouais elle était sortie 10 ans
avant elle avait bien marché sans plus
le jour où tu as ressorti ça là
tout l'été parce qu'on va on repart je
reparts encore l'été prochain dans les
festivals il y a on a fait un festival
l'année dernière à 30000 personnes à
poupée poupée des railes il y a a que
des gamins qui chantent ça moi je suis
étné j'ai quand même 70 PES dernière
fois que j'étais venus je les avais pas
encore et ben ça fait pas mal genre
c'est vrai bien je trouve en forme ouais
ouais et je prends rien ah tu vas voir
je prends rien je je fume trop je bois
du café et je ne prends rien je je suis
en dehors de la télé déjà ça me fait du
bien parce que j'ai pas cette pression
tu sais de j'ai aucune pression de speed
et puis je vais je vais sur scène et je
m'éclate sur scène voilà j'en ai rien à
Carreri je vous regarde le soir un amour
mon chéri tuas vu regarde le soir on est
bien on est tranquille là tu as regardé
mon complément d'enquête bien sûr je
l'ai
regardé bien sûr j'ai regardé j'ai g
regardé le tien j'ai regardé celui de
Gérard je me suis dit que bon ça y est
c'est la chasse à l'omme blanche pas
quelle va être le prochain qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire Bigard aichman je sais
pas
moi qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise
c'est c'est déjà les témoignages
anonymes ça me ça tu as deux trucs tu as
dans le premier complément d'enquête sur
le tiens il y a un témoignage anonyme et
sur sur Gérard il y a des images
volées quel que soit le contenu pour de
par il y a quand même des femmes qui ont
porté plein pour viol just ou mais
encore une fois a de chos dans le truc
de Gérard il y a deux choses il y a les
propos tu peux pas cautionner c'est pas
possible ce que tu as vu et puis le viol
c'est une plainte mais pour l'instant
encore une fois et c'est on va attendre
que la justice décide c'est moi le
tribunal médiatique m'emmerde vraiment
quoi j'étais avec Harry habitant
récemment il m'a dit j'étais innocenté
qui le sait c'est vrai alors que quand
c'est sorti tout le monde s précipité
dessus attendant que les gens soient
jugés après sur le fond du propos sur ce
que j'ai vu c'est vrai que j'étais gêné
quand même j'étais choqué mais
bon reportage'pp j'ai vu que le
reportage s'appelait l'ogre de pardu et
j'ai zappé minutes après je vous jure
que c'est vrai jeis tombé sur fournir
l'ogre c'est pas les mêmes c'est le même
mot mais c'est pas les mêmes donc
effectivement c'est difficile mais tous
ces trucs là bon tu as bossé là-dedans
tu le sais ah il en est sorti regardle
comme il est beau moi honnêtement je
regarde ça faisant mon avis qui
intéresse personne d'ailleurs si mais si
arrête tes conneries mais
euh tu sais je disais j'en parlais tout
à l'heure dans le couloir quand on étais
gamin à l'école le cfteur ouais on lui
cassait la gueule dans les coures récré
aujourd'hui on lui file des médailles la
délation c'est à la mode c'estàd c'est à
celui qui va balancer le plus je sais
pas c'est pas mes valeurs c'est pas ce
qu'on m' appris quand j'étais petit
euh voilà et puis c'est toujours c'est
toujours une part des gens Gérard ce
qu'on a vu c'est vrai que c'est c'est
très choquant mais c'est pas on peut pas
le réduire qu'à
ça parlez jamais des femmes vous parlez
jamais des femmes et des victimeses il y
a quand même des
victimes mais bien sûr qu'il y a des
victimes
cour sur Youtube va sur Youtube et va
écouter une chanson que j'ai faite qui
s'appelle elle marche sous la pluie tu
sauras exactement ce que je pense de ça
où j'encourage les nan à aller parler
justement àer porter plainte on en parle
des victimes j'ais bien qu'elle passe
cette chanson elle est vachement belle
on la mettre elle marche sous la pluie
ou elle s'appelle elle marche sous plus
allez voir si vous êtes devant votre
truc YouTube allez l'écouter vous allez
voir et et je prendrai toujours la
défense de ces gens-là après il y a une
mesure à avoir une part des choses euh
de par Dieu le réduire qu'à ça c'est pas
assez comme réduire Cyril que je suis
puissant j'emmerde tout le monde c'est
pas que ça vous le savez très
bien c'est ce qui c'est ce qui sortait
du du truc c'était j'ai peur de personne
j'enmer tout le monde c'est pas que ça
moi je connais un peu Cyril très bien
elle le connaî encore mieux que moi
c'est pas que ça voilà donc merf c'est
réducteur c'est comme moi oh
c'est
génialadore à Patrick Sébastien merci
patri
hier hier on
a hier hier on a rigolé on